dans le ciel de Kief les oiseaux fuient
les explosions toute la nuit la capitale
ukrainienne a été bombardée provoquant
la mort de plusieurs
civiles plus de 250000 personnes sont
actuellement privé d'électricité à
keV le maire Vitalie klitko inspecte les
dégâts près d'un immeuble visé par les
roquettes
russes encore une autre attaque brutale
sur notre ville de
sol vous pouvez voir un cratère derrière
moi l'éclat d'obu est tombé à 10 m des
habitations tout l'immeuble est
endommagé les habitants sont maintenant
évacués une vieille dame en route pour
l'hôpital et malheureusement décédé de
ces
blessures des attaques ont aussi touché
la ville de carkif dans le nord-est de
l'Ukraine sur ces images les secours
aident les habitants pris au piège dans
leurs appartements
à l'intérieur on force les portes pour
vérifier qu'il n'y a plus
personne plus que jamais le président
Zelenski appelle à la solidarité
nationale et
internationale je remercie les services
de secours d'urgence la police les
médecins tous ceux qui aident les autres
notre Armée de l'Air notre système
entier aérien nos pompiers je vous
remercie
vraiment je veux aussi remercier tous
ceux qui nous aident à travers le monde
avec leur technologie les systèmes
patriotes Nass ont chacun sauvé des
centaines de vies au moins et pour
chaque vie perdue la Russie devra
répondre gloire à
l'Ukraine ces attaques interviennent
alors que Vladimir Poutine a promis
d'intensifier les frappes en Ukraine
après le bombardement d'une ampleur sans
précédent sur la ville russe de Belgorod
le weekend dernier